presque partout au canada il sera
possible de cultiver d'acheter et de
consommer du cannabis en toute légalité
en fait presque partout parce que les
règles varient d'une province ou d'un
territoire à l'autre par exemple au
québec et en alberta il faut être âgé de
18 ans partout ailleurs au canada il
faut avoir 19 ans mais que peut-on
acheter du cannabis séchées en huile ou
en grains pour les biscuits et les
autres aliments à base de cannabis ce ne
sera pas pour tout de suite
probablement d'ici un an maintenant où
peut-on acheter ce cannabis légal dans
les magasins gouvernementaux comme ici
au québec ou dans des magasins privés et
toujours selon la province ou le
territoire où vous vous trouvez et puis
bien sûr il y aussi l'achat en ligne
[Musique]
quelle quantité peut-on possédé jusqu'à
un maximum de 30 grammes par personne
majeure ou 150 grammes par foyer peut-on
cultiver de la marijuana à domicile oui
jusqu'à un maximum de quatre plans sauf
au québec et au manitoba qui interdisent
toute culture ce qui va d'ailleurs à
l'encontre de la loi fédérale
peut-on fumée où on veut c'est là que ça
se corse
en principe il sera interdit de
consommer partout là où le tabac est
déjà prohibées et à cela il faut ajouter
aussi une multitude d'autres endroits
publics
et dans les parcs pour enfants comme
celui ci par exemple depuis l'annnonce
de la légalisation du cannabis des
dizaines et des dizaines de villes et de
municipalités ont décidé de bannir
complètement la consommation de cannabis
donc tous les lieux publics un peu comme
il est interdit de consommer de l'alcool
dans la rue par exemple
par conséquent ceux qui veulent fumer
leurs joints devons le faire sur le
terrain de leur propriété ou encore à
l'intérieur de leur résidence
mais que se passe-t-il si vous louez un
logement techniquement votre
propriétaire pourrait vous faire signer
un nouveau bail mentionnant
l'interdiction de fumer du cannabis
comme il a peut être déjà fait
précédemment à propos de la cigarette
certaines villes vont plus loin en
interdisant d'être sous l'influencé du
cannabis sur la voie publique
évidemment peu importe la ville il sera
interdit de conduire avec des facultés
affaiblies
à cause de cette drogue douce
comment tous ces règlements vont ils
être appliquée difficile à savoir
après tout le canada n'est que le
deuxième pays dans le monde à légaliser
complètement le cannabis c'est presque
une expérience de laboratoire